from bloomberg quick take i'm madison
mills
polls indicate that the economy is one
of the biggest factors influencing
how people will cast their ballots this
election year
joining us to discuss how either
candidate could impact your money
is creedy gupta from bloomberg news
creedy thank you so much for making time
on your very hectic night of covering
this election how are you
well thanks for having me it's a busy
night but this is this is a good break
to have always
i'm glad you're seeing this as a break
that's wonderful news uh creedy first
can you just talk to me about
uh the stimulus package this is
something that's on the minds of
millions of americans how could either
candidate
influence what happens next with
stimulus funding
well of course we've heard from both
candidates really coming out and saying
that they really
want a major stimulus package we've
heard from president trump
who has struggled to really get the gop
on board
the senate gopa should be specific for
that huge package especially when the
house democrats have come
forward proposing a 2.2 trillion dollar
aid package
so really when you're seeing a biden
victory that whole process seems a whole
lot easier because you have that house
democrat support
a trump victory would mean the same
thing but the real stickler here
is going to be that senate race and
that's really what markets in particular
are watching because in the past few
months
you've seen president trump you've seen
house democrats really come together
and make this bipartisan deal but it's
the senate uh gop that's really said
well hold on we need to be more fiscally
conservative we need to hold up
on this major comprehensive package and
target areas instead so things like
airline aid things like um furloughing
preventing the furloughing of airline
workers or small businesses and
restaurants so
two different approaches there but it's
really the senate race you want some
you want some sort of indication uh from
the house the presidency
and the senate that all together they're
going to come together and they're going
to get the deal passed
and zeroing in on markets what are we
going to see
at the open and close of the trading day
tomorrow
well your guess is as good as mine
honestly i mean you're seeing just in
the first few hours of overnight trading
you've already seen markets swing back
and forth so
a big kind of point to make here is your
guest could
possibly be based on what's happened
back in 2016
in the 2016 election you saw president
trump make that surprise victory
and overnight you saw markets really
tank but then the next day people
realized well hold on a second
president trump has a lot of pro-growth
policies he's cutting the tax rate
maybe this could be good for the economy
and good for stocks in general so you
saw the market kind of flip
but tomorrow we're in a different era
here we have a pandemic
we have a contracting economy we have
that stimulus up in the air
so it's really hard to say whether
you're going to see that same flip the
only thing you're really certain of
is potential volatility and price swings
not just today not just tomorrow
but potentially in the rest of the week
as well
and how could a potential contested
election
impact voters financially
um it would hurt it would really hurt
and that would show up in the markets to
begin with because of course they're
trading
really quickly and that contested
election could not only
mean uh some uncertainty in the markets
the number one rule in your trading
markets that uncertainty is not your
friend
and going back to the 2000 example where
you saw the race between al gore
and george w bush the s p 500 actually
took
a major hit when it was going through
the contested election you saw a
correction about 10 percent
and that really hits people who have
exposure to stocks through their
retirement funds
or through um kind of personal pension
accounts or things like that
so you see the pain almost immediately
um in this particular circumstance i
mean that contestant election
or just the fact of a delayed election
could have uh
more time to begin with and take an even
bigger
hit on stocks just given the uncertainty
that we're in so far
right and looking a little bit more
closely at the results that are coming
in tonight
how could uh swing states impact the
markets
as we head into uh this time where we
may not have
a clear answer on who the winner is well
that's a great question
florida is definitely in the spotlight
and that's a big one that people are
watching north carolina
ohio pennsylvania even so a lot of these
swing states are actually coming
um out shortly uh if they haven't
already actually haven't looked at my
screens but
those are really going to change how the
market is viewing the possibility
of a trump victory now going into
tonight you really saw the markets
go all in on a blue wave trade so that
means really
going forward for cyclical stocks for
the oil sector
for people that could benefit from a
buyer's containment measure from that
additional stimulus so a lot of those
small businesses a lot of the small cap
stocks
that really need that additional funding
airlines even are another example so
going into tonight you really saw the
market positioning for that
but then once again um if it all flips
because the swing states that
shows up in the markets immediately you
see those risk gauges pull back you say
hold on a second
we shouldn't be running too fast and
you've already seen that happen a few
times uh just in the last few hours
and you mentioned the importance of the
impact of the winner on
these specific sectors but uh more
specifically looking at how it could
just impact
our viewers wallets what are some of the
things that either candidate if they win
could be doing that could influence our
money
that's a great question i mean i've been
talking about the market uh impact which
of course would show up in pension funds
and
in your retirement savings account so
that's one aspect of it but just looking
long-term pulling back and looking
long-term
i'd like to give you the pros and cons
of each candidate and let's start with
biden here
biden has talked about a major
infrastructure spending package so that
of course would help
industries um and workers in particular
create jobs in sectors
of like oil which is a huge example
create sectors in
in metals create industrial jobs um
stocks like caterpillar like deer
those would all benefit as well not to
mention just put a little extra money in
the pockets of small business owners so
that's a big one
on the other flip side a big pro of
president trump is the fact that
he's talking about lowering the
corporate tax rate he's already done
that from 28
to about 21 back in 2017 he's talking
about lowering it even further
down to 15 that's a big help for
corporate america
because that means that in theory and i
do specify in theory
it would mean more hiring from some of
the country's biggest names
and of course help their stock as well
greedy gupta thank you so much for
joining us during your incredibly busy
night covering this election
uh for everyone watching we'll continue
to go live on quick take throughout the
night so follow us here for more and
thank you so much